all right benny yes benny uh where'd you
grow up where are you from
originally right here right here in
cross lanes west virginia
and tell me about your uh childhood
growing up you had mom and dad
yeah my mom and dad until five days ago
i lost my mother i'm sorry
i had uh five brothers and sisters
i've lost them all i'm the only one left
how'd you lose all your siblings the
violence and drugs
offered you in school i uh
went to 11th grade and i finished my
education in
federal penitentiary
how would you describe your childhood i
had a great childhood
uh growing up here on this farm with 100
acres
give or take uh you know
every kid's dream horses and you know
good mom and dad
had to do chores and you know work for a
living pretty much
we lived off this farm for a long time
lived off of it actually
you know that's what we're doing food
yeah still do
uh i had all my brothers and sisters
you know but it was too
you know through the 80s is when it
started you know everything started
changing
you know my in my teenage years i was
born in 1971
yeah apache has changed a lot and uh
you know uh all my siblings before me
was into some kind of mayhem
you know drugs of some sort marijuana
something you know
and marijuana formed
into cocaine methamphetamines
and the epidemic now is heroin here in
west virginia
and a little bit of all of it took in
some part of my family my brothers and
my sisters
but were they all addictions or yeah
overdoses well my oldest brother
james he was an alcoholic and
he killed a man
took his life with a 12-gauge shotgun
and
he took it to trial and everything and
me and my other brothers were you know
we were in the things that we were
supposed to be into
we ended up
robbing the police their evidence locker
and they tied it into
that murder saying we trying to steal
the evidence to get him off and stuff
they hit nationwide and
you know made us out to be some kind of
gangsters
you know my little brother pulled some
time for that
and uh but they're still not happy with
us
in putman county here in west virginia
so that that brother
uh that was convicted of murder no my
youngest brother got murdered
oh i see he oh uh some some
kid hit him in the back of the ball bat
over 300
i had to pull the plug on my little
brother
support wasn't going to do it so that
was one thing i done that was hard
uh that was a crack gimmick
every name again just swept through here
uh so i ended up becoming a crack dealer
i'm
traveling back and forth to new york i
went to prison in new york
spent about 14 months on rikers island
uh i ended up beating that in trial but
it took a while
some ingenuity some money
and i came back home and uh one year
later caught a federal charge
for uh methamphetamine
took it to trial didn't fare so well i
ended up going 100 months
and got out and
still done my own ways started you know
back dealing and heroin
when i come home heroin had taken over
peels and heroin
and methamphetamine and
uh needles took uh
two of my brother three two of my
brothers and my sister the dirty needles
endocarditis and it was a horrible death
for him
um
i never touched i never touched a needle
or an opiate until
three years ago i'm a heroin addict now
uh
my sister was the last sibling to go
i took that pretty hard i just i
disappeared for a couple weeks
about three weeks into the woods
um
uh i vote i vote several times four or
five times
um a couple of times
by me doing it on purpose a couple times
not
you know lost my leg
that brings sadness upon me misery
pain you know but
i keep on living uh and my mom wanted me
to outlive her i outlived her
you know it was hard watching my mom
lose all of her kids
and and getting older and every time
that something happens
you know uh
but i i keep returning home here i moved
out of this hauler several times
always find myself right back here you
grew up in this house
i in all these houses
um
you know it's it's hard i
had diabetes i beat diabetes and the day
i found out
diabetes i get hit by a truck that's my
last leg
yeah not from diabetes which many people
lose their legs from
yeah but that's right no it wasn't i i
had type 2 and i started
i lost a lot of weight i done it the
wrong way but i ended up in a coma doing
it
using methamphetamine don't do that
you know i lost 165 pounds in 90 days
but uh don't do as i do
do you have kids of your own yeah i got
a girl that's uh 12 years old
she don't live here she lives with her
mother i've got joint custody but she's
better off with her mother
my mother's a good woman
but this holler has been like a safe
haven for
you know people that has no nowhere to
go
uh they come here and they can work for
my dad or whatever
my mom and then we feed them take care
of you know
some were good people some are bad
people you know
but people come and go here you know uh
when i was young you know me and my
brothers we raised hell
you know we like to fight and drink you
know if we couldn't find somebody to
fight we'd fight ourselves
simple as that and that's kind of kind
of
kind of what put the no-no on the hauler
as far as outsiders coming in
you know you don't want to go there you
know they're meeting snakes or
you know mostly the mothers tell their
children is haunted stay out there
but you know it's just a place like any
other but
you know it's it's gained its authority
over the years you know
but what do you make of this region the
future of it you know because it used to
be a really
wholesome wonderful place to live and
then it turned into
the drugs just changed it if the drugs
and stuff don't disappear
everybody here is going to disappear
you know the old-timers are dying out
and you know the baby boomers versus me
are killing ourselves with the drugs
you know drugs murder mayhem was all i
live for
back in the day you know i always
dreamed to be a musician and i was one
for a while
and moving to california but
i ended up in a hospital
and uh when i broke my back and i
couldn't i couldn't stand to do a whole
set
so i went back to my old roots
slinged up got to live
government don't give me enough to live
on that's for sure
and uh
so you know it pretty much took you know
me as a kid breaking my back and
you know kind of took a lot of my dreams
away so
i just done what i was seemed like i was
born to do just
do drugs and sell drugs but you know
it's not that it's not the thing to do
i look back on it now i wish i had never
picked it up or done it but
it just seemed like i was faded into
that it's interesting that you had
what you described as a nice childhood
yeah yeah my mom and dad were
good with some clean folks never done to
touch a drug
but yeah you and your siblings all kind
of took the same run
yeah yeah but like say but you know my
you know my my sisters and my brothers
he was all smoking herb and
you know back in the 80s and once you
touch one
keep going i mean that's just that's the
truth of it
you know i never i never you know listen
to this as an intricate drug to
to other drugs it is pot yeah i mean it
is
it's a gateway it it's a gateway you
know once you get high here you want to
get high
something else i mean that's what it was
for me for everybody
it seems it's it's everyone draws a line
as to where
you know some people stronger you know
you got to be stronger than the drug
you're doing
i'd say but other than that
everyone draws a line as to where they
won't
what they won't cross over and if you do
a pot then that
but i belie i believe a lot of people
can can
draw that line and keep on the other
side of it and a lot of people can't
i mean hell the proofs are proof
everybody you know
everywhere you go somebody's on on some
heavy drugs it's just everywhere
and where they start at what are they
going to tell you
nothing usually you start out smoking
some wings you know i don't know anybody
just
started using heroin just out you know
first you know but i'm sure there's
somebody out there
but what's your biggest regret
he's doing drugs
you know because i'm not a dummy you
know i mean uh
i could have done many things have been
anything i wanted to be
but i made my choices and this is where
i ended up being
right here just disabled and
you know it's not my fault but you know
there's a reason for everything god has
a plan for everything
you know maybe i'm being punished for
the things i've done and got away with
over the
over the years you know what what kind
of emotions you go through
you know i go through a lot of a lot of
depression sadness
you know you know i did some things in
my life i won't talk about but
you know that i wish i wouldn't have
done because it gives me nightmares you
know
this gives me nightmares you know it
never did knock me out you know i
watched the truck running completely
over me
several times you know flopping
underneath my truck me and my bike
you know i watched my leg get torn from
me
yeah this this was done from uh
searching for heroin at 6 59 a.m on a
thursday morning
when normal people are sleeping or going
to work
um you know i you know i i
i just regret the drugs coming in into
my family's life period because it's for
it's for a big wonderful family in the
to me
i'm i'm i'm off left of my immediate
family
out of six of us
you know one way or the other the
alcohol
or the drugs is taking all my siblings
away
you know
you know uh it's not fun always looking
over your shoulder for the for the
police to be
looking for you you know even if they
ain't looking for you if they see me
they're gonna
they'll check me just because of who i
am
that's not a way to live it's not a way
to live at all
i mean i i you know i perceive my you
know
education and stuff when i was locked up
in prison you know it didn't give me no
good besides getting me solitary while i
was there but
i could have done something with it when
i got out then 12 years ago
but
it's just a draw it's too great the
money's too great
the action is part of the problem that
there isn't a whole lot
of things to do for people here here in
this part of west virginia
no there's nothing to do besides gamble
that's all that's uh
you guys road and that's all there is to
do this gamble if you gamble
the gambler's home got no money game of
money got no home
you know i thought i thought of the
money in machines money i couldn't
afford money i needed to pay a bill with
uh but that's all cheer there's nothing
there's no there's no fun nothing like
that you know
i say i used to play music for fun and
stuff i can't even hold a guitar anymore
uh
you know so you know a lot of people you
know
from from my era you know baby boomer
you know we everyone i know gets high
every
every single person and i know hundreds
of people
you know
i pray my daughter will change change
things from
you know and that's why i kind of keep
her away
what kept you from leading money
i have money to leave if i could pack up
right now i'd be gone
but you can't leave on 700 a month
or i'd be gone
you know i just
depression it just it eats me away
and it makes me want to get high you
know i've seek help a couple few times
you know
they always always end up going back
you know addiction of any kind something
that's that's
that's it's just it's hard to beat
you know uh
i always you know when i do leave i end
up coming back i moved to myrtle beach
once and came back loved it there
um
but it's now it just seems really really
dead here to me it's changed
um i got a cell phone
and uh i don't think it's ever ring
uh all my brothers and sisters are gone
those were my best friends
and my mom
you know
my youngest brother was given a second
chance you know they repaired his heart
and he didn't stop and four weeks later
he was gone
so that goes to show you that you know
anybody
especially me that you know if i don't
stop i'm gonna be gone
which most of the time i don't care you
know i'm ready to go anyway
it just seems like to me i've got i
can't find anything
to live for i mean my daughter is here
there but
what good is it an addict to to a small
child
how old are you now i'm i'm i just
turned 53 days ago
i raised my little girl until she was
five
but she was conceived the day i got out
of prison
and
you know that you know it's been hard on
my mom
my dad you know my dad my dad you know
he's grieving right now
uh anything it really really hit me and
my mom's gone
it will i don't know what will happen
then
but it just seemed like i'm out of tears
but it seemed like you've been through a
lot um
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
is that drugs and alcohol
will ruin a life
it has ruined my life all the way around
360 degrees
everything in my life has been destroyed
from drugs or alcohol
everything that i loved and cared about
and that's that's that's the worst
regret i have is the drugs and alcohol
come into my life
into my family's life
i mean i have all the bad things i've
done
i regret the drug use
i mean it was all fun and games and
stuff while we was all still here doing
it but when we all started disappearing
things started to change now this is
just a shadow
of what it used to be you know you know
i
you know i can close my eyes and see my
brothers my sisters walking up down the
road and
playing with one another you know even
even as
adults you know sitting here here and
hearing them you don't hear nothing now
you don't hear nothing now
but um you know from from from a
teenager to
50 years old i've done nothing but
ruined my life
with drugs there was an alcoholic but
but i've done a lot of drugs
you know uh
i've been on the run from the law you
know
get myself up you know everything he's
just
been caught several times
you know i paid my dues
but now it just seems like there's
nothing left besides just to sit and
fade away that's the way i feel
you know i mean you know you gotta give
me a brain
and and choices in in
to make but seems like i made all the
wrong ones
you know because it's hard you know when
you're sitting out here and there's
nothing much to do and somebody hey
let's go do this and this and that
let's go bro you know we
uh
yeah but i you know i'm still here i
came a long way i was paralyzed from the
waist down
from diving off a bridge i hit the water
wrong and hyperextending me
crushed my spine had it reconstructed
i had kidney failure died from that
in the hospital about four months on
that
but yeah i walk out and i crawl the
hospital nine days later with this
you know i say i'm the third generation
here you know
washington's were fading away so i never
thought would happen
i've got a few nieces and nephews but if
they don't
if they don't change and get on the
right path it's going to be the same
thing
all right benny thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck and if you
show us to somebody maybe they'll
they'll change it maybe they'll stop
what they're doing
it's just not going to work the drugs
don't work out
in the end this is what you'll be if you
keep it up
or if you're lucky you'll end up dirt
over top of you instead of living it
like this
but i've got five brothers and sisters
right there in the graveyard
remind me every day
it's just wow
and this is rural west virginia you know
what i mean
middle of nowhere yeah i mean you think
it's crazy here i can imagine what it's
like in los angeles or somewhere
i think it's crazier here
could be